[Musik]
christina/sn archiv geboren und
aufgewachsen
dort hat sie sich mit ihrem freund ein
leben aufgebaut wie so viele wurde die
21-jährige vom krieg überrascht
[Musik]
ich habe den bombenangriff zuerst gar
nicht gehört um fünf uhr morgens fing es
an und nach einer stunde habe ich einen
anruf von meinem papa bekommen und mich
gefragt wo man gehört warum ruft mich
dein papa an ist etwa der krieg
ausgebrochen
und ja der krieg war wirklich
christina und ihr freund fliehen mit dem
zug fahren sie nach lemberg ihre
heimatstadt aktiv und die familie lassen
sie hinter sich
ihre träume ihre pläne
ausgelöst durch putins krieg die junge
marketing-expertin macht sich nicht nur
sorgen um ihre eigene zukunft sondern um
die eines ganzen landes
ich habe angst dass es keine ukraine
mehr auf der weltkarte gibt wenn das
hier vorbei ist
das ist meine größte angst
ich hoffe dass wir dieses land wieder
aufbauen werden denn ich liebe es
wirklich sehr
in lemberg angekommen versucht die
21-jährige sich auf das positive zu
konzentrieren
das war der glücklichste moment der
ganzen woche
ich hatte normales essen und konnte mir
sogar meine haare waschen das ist
absolut fantastisch
in paket war das nicht möglich
doch dieses gute gefühl hält nur kurz
schnell fühlt sie sich schuldig denkt
ihre familie in archiv im stich gelassen
zu haben
ich hasse mich weil ich duschen konnte
ich hasse mich weil ich internet habe
ich hasse mich weil sie in kharkiv sind
und ich hier in sicherheit bin
[Musik]
ein bekannter schickt christina fotos
wie sie versuchen die menschen den truck
tief mit dem nötigsten zu versorgen
christina ist in stetigem austausch mit
familie und freunden
[Musik]
ich habe meine mutter gebeten dass sie
aus rache fliehen
sie haben die ganze nacht darüber
nachgedacht aber
morgen sagte sie mir sie wollen doch
bleiben
juli hob ist in haag kurz nach
kriegsbeginn haben wir das erste mal
kontakt zu ihm in friedenszeiten ist er
ein glühender fußballfan
münchen amsterdam kein stadion ist ihm
und seiner frau victoria zu weit jetzt
sitzt er bomben keller seiner
heimatstadt
werden nicht nur militärobjekte
beschossen sondern auch normale
wohnhäuser wir können nicht rausgehen um
frische luft zu schnappen
mit ihm im keller mitten im zentrum von
prag tipps sind auch seine frau die
hausbewohner mit hunden und katzen
wir hoffen dass unsere partner uns dabei
helfen diesen idioten diesen feind zu
stoppen
kharkiv steht seit tagen unter beschuss
in der nacht sollen viele zivilisten
getötet worden sein
[Musik]
wir bleiben im schutzkeller
weil in der stadt sehr viele saboteure
unterwegs sind
legen sprengsätzen und töten menschen
auf den straßen
tag für tag versucht juli an
lebensmittel zukommen für seine familie
und die menschen im haus auch benzin ist
mangelware in haag
die stadt ist sehr groß und die menschen
brauchen benzin zu den supermärkten zu
kommen die geöffnet haben die leute in
den autos warten überstunden aber das
ist nötig um hier zu überleben
juli ist ein käufer für supermärkte und
zeigt uns die leeren regale
es gibt kaum brot sagt er kein fleisch
keine milch es gibt keinen gries keine
glauben mehr eine palette frische eier
sofort weg
vor drei tagen wird ein wohnkomplex
getroffen mittlerweile soll es über 150
tote in der stadt geben kharkiv hatte
mal anderthalb millionen einwohner wie
viele jetzt noch hier ausharren weiß
keiner
wir sind gerade zu einer quelle gefahren
um wasser für die bewohner unseres
hauses zu holen sie können nicht raus
es wird gerade geschossen aber nicht
hier in diesem bezirk
juli versucht seine frau und verwandte
so schnell wie möglich aus der stadt
raus zu kriegen es ist zu gefährlich
dann scheint es doch noch einen weg zu
geben
das ist der dreizehnte tag des krieges
wir sind am bahnhof und versuchen jetzt
unsere familien zu evakuieren
stehen vor dem zug und hoffen dass alles
klappt
seine frau victoria wird nun den weg an
die polnische grenze ohne ihn antreten
wir sind am bahnhof im prinzip ist alles
gut wir sind am leben
seine frau hat es geschafft hören wir
später juli will weiterhelfen in hf über
500 km weiter südlich in rason versteckt
sich katharina
ich weiß nicht ob das hier nicht mein
letztes gespräch ist ich schreibe meinem
freund die ganze zeit dass ich ihn liebe
weil ich nicht weiß welche nachricht
welche nachricht die letzte sein könnte
katharinas freund ist denn seit zwei
jahren führen sie eine fernbeziehung sie
in der ukraine er in dänemark jetzt ist
sie im krieg er mehr als 2000 kilometer
entfernt
es ist wirklich die hölle du kannst
nicht aufhören daran zu denken was
gerade in der ukraine passiert was da
gerade mit meiner freundin passiert
weihnachten haben sie noch zusammen
gefeiert sind mit zukunftsplänen ins
neue jahr gestartet
[Musik]
im märz wollten wir zusammenziehen aber
es war wohl nicht der richtige zeitpunkt
es war einfach schlechtes timing
ende januar sehen sie sich zum letzten
mal beim abschied hat anders kein gutes
gefühl als hätte er geahnt dass ihnen
schwere zeiten bevorstünden
ich erinnere mich dass dieser konflikt
in den nachrichten immer präsenter wurde
und ich dachte vielleicht ist das ein
fehler sie jetzt gehen zu lassen
wie sehr er sich wünscht dass er sich
geirrt hätte doch seine befürchtung
wurde leider war
am abend vor den ersten angriffen waren
ihre eltern schon sehr besorgt sie
wollten dass katharina das land verlässt
also suchten wir ein flugticket für den
6 märz aber am nächsten morgen wachte
ich auf als sie mir ein foto der
explosionswolke schickt mit den worten
es geht los
katharinas familie hat ein kleines
geschäft in den ersten tagen versorgen
sie ihre nachbarn noch mit lebensmitteln
doch als die russischen soldaten immer
näher rücken wird es zu gefährlich
wir wollten nicht dass wir uns
erschießen weil sie hungrig sind und
hier her kommen und unser ganzes essen
nehmen also haben wir uns versteckt
person ist die erste große stadt die von
russischen streitkräften besetzt wird
trotzdem trauen sich menschen auf die
straße und protestieren gegen den krieg
katharina nicht zu groß die angst das
haus zu verlassen lebensmittel haben sie
noch auf vorrat rausgehen sie nur um
fenster und türen zu verriegeln
wir sind gefangen in unserer eigenen
stadt wir sind gefangen in unseren
eigenen häusern wir sind gefangene und
wir sind machtlos
das hier ist unser unterschlupf wo wir
schlafen
hier ist platz für meine mutter dahinter
für mich und auf der seite für meinen
vater
natürlich habe ich angst vor allem musik
ich habe jeden moment angst dass sie
etwas zustößt ich versuche ihr das nicht
zu sehr zu zeigen
ich will zu meinem freund und dort
bleiben sonst zerreißt es mir das herz
ich will einfach in sicherheit sein das
ist mein plan
und an diesem plan halten sie fest
bis sie sich wieder sehen
[Musik]